all right let's go straight to the
phones we're going to talk to marie in
north carolina
except that is not north carolina that
is new york city said the former
geography teacher
think got everybody i was in high school
classrooms shaping hearts and minds at
one point
what's up marie how are you hi doctor
john i'm so excited to talk to you today
i'm excited to have you get excited i am
glad that you're in new york and not
north carolina because
i live i taught geography what an idiot
hey so what's up how can i help okay so
my husband and i we cannot agree about
having children
and a lot of it has to do with him being
in law enforcement
oof it has been a year or two for your
family hasn't it
yes it's been really hard yeah really
tough and i got law enforcement family
too it has been a
messy messy year all every feeling every
everything right
yep yep all right so tell me about these
fights you're having
okay so uh i'll give you a little bit of
background we've been married for six
years
i'm 30 he's on he's almost 40. um i grew
up
in a law enforcement family as well my
father my grandfather
my father was in an elite unit in this
in new york city and he was never home
um so i kind of grew up like with my mom
really struggling um doing a lot of
things alone
raising us alone watching her cry a lot
and now that i'm older she
always says that she feels like she felt
like a single mom she there's three of
us so she felt like she's a single mom
raising three kids um so now that we're
older my husband has not been
in law enforcement our whole marriage he
got in when we were married for
three years uh or two years i don't know
he's been on for four years now
um and we like like like we both knew we
wanted kids but we've never like i've
never felt precious to have them he's
never pressured me
but now i feel like i don't want to feel
like a single mom
and i feel like i don't want to raise my
children while my husband is working
12-hour shifts every day working
overtime
barely getting two days off a week
coming home
stressed out and don't get me wrong he's
amazing like i
won the the prize with him like i really
did
but i mean like there's like his job is
stressful that's just the reality
and i don't want to be
not that i feel like he would do this
but i feel like it's a possibility like
i don't want to be a punching bag for
his emotions
and then having having to take care of
kids and then having to give up my
own life it's just it's just really
frustrating and he's getting to an
age because he is 10 years older than me
that he's like all right
like i'm ready for children and i'm like
all right well i'm really not
and i don't and i don't really want to
do this by myself
and that's what i see happening for me
is me doing it by myself
gotcha thank you for being brave
that's not an easy thing to say out loud
all that stuff you just said
yeah so you know this but i'm gonna say
it out loud okay
your husband's not your dad is he
no he's not but you carry a lot of your
dad around
in your backpack don't you way too much
honestly
way too much
it sounds like you are more at war with
your old man and this
job that stole your dad than you are
your husband is that fair
i think that's fair so you think
man you said he won the lottery he's a
great guy serving his community he loves
you like crazy
what have you seen in him that makes you
think he's going to disappear on you
nothing like dr john he's amazing
like he's an amazing person i
there he would be the best of freaking
dad
ever like he would be the best dad
he would be so hands-on he would
really take care of me but i am just so
like i'm so afraid and i just remember
like
turning 18 and finding out that like my
you know my dad had some infidelities um
you know like while he was obviously
where he's retired now my parents are
really great and
they worked they worked through those
infidelities they did
but i saw my mom cry so much
and i saw her do work through that alone
too mostly alone honestly and i just
i don't know i i love my husband he's
just like i said he's the freaking best
but
i feel like every anybody is capable of
anything
and i feel like any situation is capable
of pain
listen i'm laughing because i do not
know
a cop's kid who who
trusts anyone i really don't
nobody right hey when you go into a
restaurant do you sit with your back to
the
to the wall yes of course i am a yes i
am a psycho
hey listen you're not psycho you're a
cops kid i'm the same way
okay um i'm meeting with a counselor
now and maybe two sessions ago the guy
was like
this psychologist he was like who do you
trust
and i was like uh
oh man my wife and he's like
you had to think about that who else and
i was like uh
todd like listen
all of your fears and insecurities are
are earned okay they're all earned
you've
lived it and here's the thing about for
those of you who don't know growing up
in the home of a cop
every single day they leave
their spouse knows they may not come
home
and it becomes so routine that we forget
those traumas just add up and add up and
add up and
add up and as a as a kid
like you just see dad you know
taking shining his shoes and cleaning
his gun and look at his bulletproof vest
and you see how tough and big and
you know wonderful that all this and the
fact he might die today
or the next day or the next day and so
all like marie all of your
stuff is well earned and can i also say
this
your dad could be a really amazing guy
and have totally not shown up for you as
a as a as a kid
it can be both hand and he may have made
some
major changes in his life because cops
in the 70s and 80s had
zero there was nothing about how to take
care of yourself
at home nothing you were you you were
you were on the clock here you're about
your community
and your kids and family were just
something that you know it's like a
hobby
right yeah and a lot of cops now are
especially the older ones are realizing
oh my gosh i gave up
everything right but it can be both hand
so your dad could have really really
sucked growing up
and your mom may have done it all by
herself and she may have done it
really hard and sometimes not very well
yeah and there's probably probably part
of you that is afraid as much afraid of
your
husband turning into your dad as you are
turning into your mom is that fair 100
oh 100 okay i my dad like my parents
were my mom was so busy taking care of
the kids and my dad was so busy working
that the only attention i was the oldest
so the only attention we really got was
disciplinary
um especially for my dad so we knew when
dad was coming from work we were gonna
get it like if we got bad grades and
i and i don't want to be that kind of
family
so listen listen listen don't
just don't
and i wish it was it was harder than
that but it's not
just choose not to be because here's
what i know about you just by this phone
call you're going to be
a incredible mom if you decide to have a
kid
incredible mom
based on what you've told me about your
husband you listen to this show right
people call and tell me all kinds of
crazy things about their husband you
like yours
a lot i love i love mine he's the
freaking best
well everyone loves their husband you
like yours that's a whole lot
that's a whole other level right yep
mm-hmm it's true
y'all are going to be incredible parents
it will take both of you saying we are
not
we are committed together
to not replay the past
and when my guess is your mom was
quote unquote really busy with the kids
and your dad was quote-unquote really
busy with the work
my guess is if you really dug into that
they were really busy
staying out of each other's way yeah
they were probably
really busy not wanting to be connected
to each other for some reasons that you
may never know about
yeah and so while i want you to hold
their experience in your hand because it
is your experience too
and those feelings of neglect and
frustration and
that pres man my wife calls it sunday
afternoon dad
that cop presence that walks in the door
you
feel it and you can be in your room door
shut listening to old like
poison cds and that that guy walks in
the door you know he's there
right it's true it's just this weight
right
that's all true and anxiety
it is it is but it's earned anxiety your
brain remembers that
and it doesn't want to do that again so
when your husband looks at you and he's
like hey i'm joining the police force
you're like oh cool and then you went oh
no all right exactly your heart took off
your stomach drops
and he calls and he's like i'm gonna be
late you're like okay that's cool
and then there's a part of your brain
that sets off an alarm that goes here we
go again
and suddenly new york's gonna be more
important than you and you watch the
news
and every day you're like oh he's not
coming home he's not coming home and
almost to the point when he comes home
it becomes a surprise
and then you lean on him a little bit
heavier and you start creating a new
world right i've been
there okay and i'm not married to a cop
i just live with one
right and so here's the thing you hold
that in one hand
and in the other hand you hold your
husband's hand really tight
and you'll say we're not doing this
we're going to put this family first
we're going to put our marriage first
and then our kids
you're going to be an incredible cop and
you're going to teach our kids what
loving their community looks like what
service really looks like
even when it's hard and scary and
you're going to show them what listening
looks like and what feelings look like
and what's saying hey i'm messed up or
i'm wrong or i'm scared looks like
you're going to show your kids what
really digging in on mom looks like
like not in a bad way and like i said
that all weird
like what love looks like gross love
like kids like quit kissing in the
kitchen
right all of those things are a choice
and that's a that's it somebody in your
family is going to have to turn and face
the forest fire
and i think it's you does that mean you
have to have kids no
but i think that you want them you just
don't want to be your mom
and i think that you want him you just
don't want him to be your dad
and all of a sudden these variables are
starting to line up oh he's got your
dad's job and oh
you don't want to be a single mom and oh
gosh that sounds like my mom and ah
and here we go right
i think y'all can do it in fact i know
you can do it
i know you can
it's about being super intentional and
saying this stops with us
and we're gonna be the greatest parents
who have ever lived
i'm gonna give you a copy of my book
redefining anxiety
y'all can use it as a road map and i
want y'all to have true
real weird hard conversations about not
weird but let's just be honest are we
gonna do this kid thing or not
and don't leave it hanging out there
don't let it just stay untethered
come up with it say we're going to talk
about it right now we're going to make a
decision we're going to wait five months
we're not going to bring it up we're not
going to discuss it
and we will agree to keep looping back
to it but let's don't let that hang over
our relationship because it's going to
start like a little splinter and then
it's going to turn into a wound and the
whole thing's going to get infected it's
going to become a mess
have it out have that hard conversation
and if you decide to have kids number
one you're going to be great
number two decide you're going to be
great number three
be about making it happen